all right our next guest best-selling
author John Grisham is giving readers an
inside look at one of the most notorious
mobs in America happens to be in the
South it's a group of criminals known as
the Dixie Mafia and they ran rampant
across the Gulf Coast and the South
starting in the late 1950s one official
at the time called them more brutal than
the Sicilian Mafia grisham's latest
fictional Thriller the boys from Biloxi
is inspired by this real life mob and it
tells the story of two sons of immigrant
families who grow up as friends but
ultimately find themselves on opposite
sides of the law and Mr Grisham joins us
now opposite sides of this camera lens
hello
good morning to you uh this is a
fantastic book and it's a classic story
of two boys who grow up best friends but
go in very different directions and you
know a showdown is coming in a courtroom
at the end what may age you personally
want to write about this particular
group of criminals from way back when
well the setting Biloxi's always
fascinated me because it's on the Gulf
Coast and uh for you know a state that's
very uh conservative in all aspects it
was uh a wide open place for many
decades and I grew up at the end of the
state outside of Memphis and North
Mississippi and we were always sort of
fascinated by the legend uh in lore of
Biloxi and the Gulf Coast and and the
Bison the crime and the corruption and
it's just a big colorful setting for a
novel
one of the young boys Keith his father
is a lawyer a prosecutor and then he
goes to law school and the best friend
they're on the criminal side of things
you were a lawyer in Mississippi were
you aware at the time of the this kind
of uh Dixie Mafia
yeah I mean by the time I got to uh to
college and law school and started
meeting we call them kids from the coast
the kids from the coast were always a
lot of a fringement but I I knew him
pretty well and and I'd been there I've
seen some of Biloxi by the end and and I
was very much aware of the uh uh the
legend and also the reality of of the
organized crime and the uh setting and
the the uncontrolled Vice that was was
rampant on the coast back in the 50s 60s
and 70s it kind of played out in the
late 1980s and then when when casino
gambling was legalized in 1990 in
Mississippi and the big casinos came in
to the coast that was pretty much the
end of the control of ice in blood
I want to start this by saying you know
I Adore You John Grisham I've read all
your books big fan but I was a little
worried about how this one started it
said a hundred years ago Biloxi was a
busing Resort and fishing community on
the Gulf Coast then it goes on to talk
about immigrants coming in I yawned a
little bit then it went to chapter two
when it starts the Rivalry began as a
friendship between two boys with much in
common the great thing that I always
find about your books John is that you
draw Us in for the first line I wasn't
drawn in with this little history lesson
the way you started it were you worried
that your readers would feel that I'm
asking were you and I'm not insulting
you I'm just asking were you worried
uh I was very worried because as you say
I I usually work hard to hook the reader
uh if not by Page One certainly by page
two and yeah it's very much a part of uh
creating immediate suspense and getting
the reader hooked in the story I was
very much worried about uh this book
because the first chapter is all history
it's all accurate uh but you know nobody
wants to read about the seafood industry
or the immigrants who built it and so I
was I got through it as fast as I could
to get to some real action but no this
is a different different type of story
no you got to some action page 51 Ginger
she was a heavyset woman of about 50
with a dress too tight cut too low in
front her breasts were pushed up close
to her chin and looked somewhat
uncomfortable I know this lady do you
know her
sure yeah we've all known that lady uh I
didn't I didn't want to talk about sex
this morning when I came on the show by
the way I said I saw you on the set of
all the gun before my covet test came
back and I tested positive so now I'm
off site so I got kicked out of CBS oh
okay okay we were trying to protect your
privacy John Grisham but since you want
to tell everybody are you feeling okay
and you have triple boosted I've had
covered top Teflon I feel great no
symptoms and I tested positive about for
the first time in several months so yeah
I can't be there no I know
I hear you on that and real quick just
like the characters in the book you were
a baseball kid growing up so any
thoughts on the World Series what do you
got
you know it's really so weird when you
have a Padres and Phillies playing for
the nationally tied I'm a Cardinal fan
uh so that's very unexpected uh so yeah
it'll be fun but it's not what I wanted
uh and you know if the Yankees make it
that's another uh I'm not a Yankee fan
by the way Nate you're you're one line
of the day I'm going to use this in a
novel The guy can't pull out the
driveway that's that's really a question
can I just say this book is a great
great great story I mean the way you
tell the tale it's a it talks about the
death penalty it talks about addiction
it's it's so well done Bravo dick with
it no no no doubt John Grisham it's
really really good just like in baseball
you knock it out of the park again the
boys from Biloxi is on sale now